I'm dr. ken Lacovara paleontologist at
Drexel University and I'm about to watch
the Jurassic world trailers for the
first time I'm conflicted on the idea of
if we could bring back dinosaurs which
we can but if we could would that be a
good idea almost certainly that would be
a bad idea we just went and made a new
dinosaur probably not a good idea
apparently they've created a hybrid
theropod dinosaur some new kind of
meat-eating dinosaur I noticed that it
has particularly long arms this is not
necessarily an improvement you know
people make fun of t-rex and as these
little puny arms or the two fingers
extra body parts are extra body parts to
be injured they're extra body parts to
nourish they're extra tissue that can go
pathological and so having short arms in
the case of a t-rex not necessarily a
disadvantage that's pretty cool so the
mosasaur that they show that's in the
shark tank
first of all not a dinosaur all
dinosaurs lived on land and except for
birds no dinosaurs ever flew so
pterosaurs like pterodactyls not
dinosaurs
big marine reptiles like mosasaurs
plesiosaurs
egg Theo Soares also not dinosaurs that
said that mosasaur is really pretty cool
it's these things are basically sea
monsters and these things have a second
set of teeth at the top of their throat
that points backwards to keep you from
swimming back out it's not far-fetched
that there could be cross species
communication it's not very plausible to
have dinosaurs that are thinking deep
thoughts they probably weren't they have
little tiny brains and they are probably
responding in a very instinctual way so
I would not try the the Chris Pratt and
move there the dinosaur whisperer thing
is probably a really good way to get
yourself eaten so I think the message
here is it's not going to end well for
you if you go to this island